[Musique]
aujourd'hui 17 octobre nouvelle édition
du 7 8 les invités l'actualité avec
celles et ceux acquise en qui en sont
les acteurs et vous entendrez ce soir
alexandre bon temps il est le fondateur
de l'antenne yvelinoise de la maison des
citoyens une maison pour compter ceux
qui ne votent pas mais aussi pour
élaborer des propositions le mot d'ordre
ne plus laisser les politiques faire des
promesses qu'ils ne tiendront pas et
puis michel tonini astronautes nous en
dira plus sur ses voyages il était à
l'école d'ingénieurs de saint quentin en
yvelines l'estac à la semaine dernière
pour partager ses aventures dans
l'espace avec les étudiants le 8
septembre dernier l'écrivain alexandre
jardin lancé la maison des citoyens une
initiative pour réunir ceux qui ne se
sentent plus représentés politiquement
ce sont prêts aujourd'hui 250 maisons
qui ont ouvert leurs portes et notamment
dans l les yvelines je reçois ce soir
l'un des architectes justement de cette
maison des yvelines c'est un autre
alexandre alexandre bon temps bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez décidé de relayer cet
appel d'alexandre jardin pourquoi tout
simplement effectivement parce que je me
suis senti concerné ne fait que des gens
se sentent pas concernés ne sont pas
pris en compte dans les politiques
actuelles et ne comptent plus
véritablement pour dans la société les
maisons des citoyens doivent permettre
de compter justement ceux qui ne se
comptent plus il y un site internet pour
sa trente mille personnes vous allez
nous histoire dépassé le cap des 30
milles devant lui sans passer un peu
plus de 30000 effectivement donc j'avais
des téléspectateurs à venir compter bien
évidemment étant la maison des citoyens
point fr exactement tout à fait pour
ceux recensés 30000 personnes alors
l'idée donc c'est de se compter mes
heures au départ c'est quoi
effectivement au départ c'est de se
compter et ensuite c'est de proposer des
actions positives et les actions des
initiatives positives dans les yvelines
puisque notre maison a été 8 septembre
quand alexandra a lancé son appel tout
de suite j'ai on n'a eu qu'une petite
équipe elle a eu l'idée de faire la
maison des citoyens des yvelines alors
autour de quoi portent les discussions
tout simplement parce que c'est une
plateforme de dialogue aussi une fois
qu'on sait compter voilà q tu es on
discute on leur en échange les
concrètement on propose des actions bien
concrètes comme par exemple comment dire
villennes-sur-seine une association qui
s'appelle vilaine initiative
d'expression est une association qui
propose d'actions positives voilà donc
c'est ça aussi le but c'est
là on est sur une démarche citoyenne
mais on imagine tout de même que
l'objectif c'est d'élaborer un programme
alors son jardin candidat a peut-être
2017 lens est un peu trop tôt pour le
dire surtout que de toute manière ce
sera pas alexandre jardin qui décidera
ce seront les citoyens véritablement qui
décideront puisqu'on est plus on n'est
pas un parti dans un premier temps on
est un mouvement citoyen et on n'est
plus dans un système justement mais
comme je le dis souvent nous dans notre
mouvement on ne lutte pas contre le
système on propose quelque chose de
nouveau alexandre jardin candidats il y
pense peut-être tout de même parce que
en tout cas on va revenir un peu sur le
sur son historique il avait déjà lancé
en 2014 bleus blancs des beurs c'est une
structure qui réunit les les faiseurs
les feux des 2e et va comme il les
appelle à 300 associations entreprises
des mairies ou autre et qui apporte des
solutions aux problèmes d'emploi
d'illettrisme et donc voilà qui agissent
qui est ce que justement comme vous
l'avez dit en préambule les politiques
bien souvent nous disent en cantons sera
élu on fera on fera si on fera ça mais
là il s'agit plus de ont fait déjà donc
les choses sont déjà en place mais cette
plateforme elle était avec créer comme
vous la vie à cinq ans pour justement
mettre en avant ses initiatives
positives mais parce que qu'est ce qui
change aujourd'hui entre bleu blanc
zèbres qui a été lancée en 2014 et puis
aujourd'hui donc cette maison du citoyen
qu'est lancée au mois de septembre et
s'élançant parce que là au départ cette
plateforme est laissée sensible faire
appel à des entrepreneurs et là sur
notre forme de du mouvement des citoyens
des yvelines
toute la france puisqu'il ya 152 ans
qu'ils ont été créés dont la vôtre dans
les yvelines dans leur ordre là
effectivement pour mettre en avant les
acteurs les citoyens c'est à dire qu'on
comptait les citoyens véritablement mais
pas forcément ceux qui font parce que
les citoyens qui font pilote qui
effectivement sont
voilà c'est rendre aussi les citoyens
acteurs de leur vie plus attendre que ça
vienne d'en haut atteindre attendre que
voilà vous faites partie des déçus de
des politiques de la politique mais des
hommes politiques des hommes et des
femmes politiques effectivement oui
parce que comme on disait il est souvent
ils nous promettent des choses puis qui
ne tiennent pas on voit beaucoup de
mouvements citoyens qui aujourd'hui
n'est ces merdes un peu partout il y en
a eu 1 qui a fait beaucoup parler et
c'était nuit debout par exemple cette
initiative vous en avez pensé quoi ben
parce que des gens de nuit debout on les
retrouve par exemple dans les maisons
des citoyens on ne sait pas affecté
c'est qu'il y ait un lien vous m'avez
posé la question à savoir s'il y avait
des combines de personnes divines venez
on ne sait pas mais peut très bien y
avoir effectivement les personnes qui
étaient présentes lors du mouvement nuit
debout parce que cette idée justement
des changes de se regrouper
de pouvoir avoir la parole redonner
redonner du sens aussi au monde à la
démocratie véritablement puisque le mot
démocratie si on découpe demos peuple
kratos pouvoir le pouvoir au peuple et
si on regarde jouer à l'heure actuel des
choses le peuple
n'a plus la parole en tout cas on ne
l'écoutent pas exactement qui sont pas
pris en compte on prend pas en compte
son avis quand en 2005 comptait voter un
texte de loi sur le traité européen et
que finalement il est appliqué alors que
le peuple avait dit non donc l'objectif
c'est pas forcément vous l'avez
différents partis un parti politique
mais en tout cas c'est de s'inscrire
dans une démarche centriste oui les
marches de droite une dénonciation du
tout de cette politique c'est pas d'une
phase politique si au sens noble du
terme parce que la police la ville la
gestion de la ville en société de la vie
en société oui mais plus savoir sans
étiquette sans étiquette d'ailleurs dans
les communes des acteurs
comment dire ruraux les acteurs les
maires les élus locaux pardon des élus
locaux pour les gens qui agissent sur le
terrain qui font déjà aussi des choses
ne sont pas forcément d'un parti des
parts il faut savoir que c'est quelque
chose qui en 1789 était conseillé
quelque chose de mal
et qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui on a
encore la même chose on a fait une
révolution parce que nous on veut pas de
révolution de violence pactole de
violences quelque chose de positif c'est
quelque chose de bienveillant d'ailleurs
ces partis d la bienveillance était
partie des valeurs de la maison des
citoyens gagnent 3 la diversité je peux
les mauvais risques c'est moi je vends
des 10e et donc la diversité c'est à
dire regrouper toutes les personnes qui
de tous les horizons de tous les
horizons justement ils peuvent venir
très bien n'importe quel horizon va pas
savoir achats de montrer où ils viennent
dont une essentielle c'est qu'ils se
reconnaissent dans notre mouvement
ensuite les actions donc les faisons et
enfin la bienveillance mais aussi
remettre un peu vite s'excuser
les îles inquiétez pas mais voilà donc
remettre en avant les territoires c'est
à dire redonner du pouvoir aux
territoires que ça devienne plus d'en
haut que sa veine plus que de paris
décentraliser un petit peu tout ça ce
dont se plaignent souvent d'un certain
mr d'ailleurs que les décisions sont
prises au plus haut et ajouter le beurre
les algériennes donc c'est ça tout à
fait parce qu'avec son jardin pour sa
part a fait tout un 3 ans depuis trois
ans le tour de la france est allé voir
les gens sur le terrain et alors c'est
pour ça qu'il fait ce mouvement aussi
c'est qu'il a récoltées tout c'est tous
ses désirs et à tous et à toutes ces
angoisses toutes ces demandes qu'il ya
dans nos pays vous parlez d'angoissé
alexandre jardin il y en a une dans
gouès c'est de voir le front national
qui montrent aussi quelque chose qu il
angoisse profondément oui parce que nice
gagne et que le front national puisse
l'emporter est-ce que c'est aussi un
point commun à toutes ces personnes qui
rejoignent vos maisons des citoyens
parce qu'effectivement la solution n'est
pas là la solution n'est pas là il faut
que les gens se disent que la solution
est tant mieux la solution elle est 7e
au site l'a pas il faut redonner
confiance aux gens et qui s'est assystem
conte qui a ancré en nous et en nous on
est un petit peu conditionné dans ce
système là donc on s'imagine pas qu'il
puisse y avoir autre chose de différent
et qu'on peut se dire tiens on a essayé
si on a essayé ce partisan essayé de
partir à qui on l'appelle c'est celui-là
c'est pas comme ça il faut que ça marche
vraiment sa confiance se faire confiance
en orient qu on ait confiance en nous et
que les actes les choses reviennent de
la base des citoyens donc première étape
lancé depuis le mois de septembre cette
maison des citoyens sur internet maison
des citoyens point fr vous vous recensez
ensuite vous allez vous réunir joie
levin faire des propositions concrètes
ça va commencer à partir de deux camps
alors les propositions déjà été recensés
parce qu'on a organisé des cafés
citoyens le 22 septembre on a organisé
un premier café citoyen les gens sont
venus présenter des choses actions
qu'ils avaient envie de mettre en place
et ensuite à partir de très
prochainement il y aura dans cette
maison des pièces qui vont s'ouvrir
c'est à dire que sur les sujets bien
précis l'éducation l'environnement
toutes les propositions qui seront
recensés dans toute la france par
exemple à bordeaux on voit qu'il ya un
jeune qui a créé une plateforme à une
plateforme une application par dons pour
venir en aide aux sans abri ça c'est du
concret il ya quelques années une
personne aussi qu'à créer un compte et
qu'on dit qu'elle mais ça c'était déjà
dans les blues n ont pas réutiliser
effectivement des faits du précédent
mouvement wimbledon est effectivement
puisque ce sont des choses qui se font
avec des résultats bien concret et l'eau
dans les yvelines aussi bien précisément
on envisage de mettre en place le la
méditation l'école de développer la
méditation à l'école je mange
interdisant par exemple dans des écoles
où je présente des ateliers aux enfants
et on voit déjà des résultats donc une
fois que tout ça c'est fait vous
réfléchissez peut-être en décembre il y
aura une candidature est peut-être un
voile à partir même si ça s'appellera
pas comme ça mais en tout cas moi la
formation maison des des citoyens et on
verra si on décembre alexandre jardin
est candidat à voir même si ça découle
sur autre chose après une toute dernière
question puisque les politiques aussi
aime beaucoup en ce moment par les deux
démarches citoyennes et d'implication
des citoyens il y en a en particulier
ces manuels macron vous l'avez rencontré
vous avez discuté avec alors justement
le ni gauche ni droite tout ça c'est
dépassé ces mouvements citoyens mais bon
effectivement
moi personnellement je n'ai pas
rencontré alexandre jardin et a été
présent lors de son premier meeting je
crois à paris l'actualité qu'il avait
organisée il y avait donc présenter ses
demandes ses attentes de nous rejoindre
et de se regrouper effectivement dans ce
même mouvement pour tenir compte des
citoyens des actions positives qui sont
mises en place par les zèbres l'autre et
à ce jour il n'y a pas eu de retour très
bien merci l'arrestation de l'avoir
présenté cette maison des citoyens qui a
ouvert donc ses portes à dans le
département des yvelines il y en a 150
aujourd'hui en france nous quittons ce
domaine citoyen le domaine de la
politique pour l'espace à présent on va
prendre encore plus de hauteur avec
thomas pesquet et qui partira en
novembre ils seront dix français avoir
eu l'opportunité d'effectuer un voyage
dans l'espace michel tonini et l'un
d'entre eux c'était même le troisième
astronautes de l'hexagone après jean
loup chrétien et patrick baudry à
s'envoler il a effectué deux voyages
spatiaux nous l'avons rencontré il était
présent à st quentin en yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux à l'estac à l
école d'ingénieur il a rencontré les
étudiants et mélanie poquet a pu
l'interroger
alors j'ai d'abord été pilote de chasse
dans l'armée de l'air ensuite j'ai été
pilote d'essais au centre d'essai en vol
et je me suis proposé à la candidature
d'astronautes en 1985 alors que j'étais
à son hôte avant j'étais pilote d'essais
pour devenir astronaute sur le programme
permet ce qu est un programme franco
européen le travail de pilote d'essai
d'hermès dame est un travail que j'avais
vraiment envie de faire mais le travail
des astronautes était un travail que
j'ai fait en parallèle qui m'aurait aidé
à être pilote d'essai sur hermès
finalement lorsque j'ai fait mon vol
spatial au retour de mon volant 92 le
programme hermès était abandonné le
premier vol c'est en 92 sur le vaisseau
soyouz la station mir décollage de
baïkonour de semaine dans la station
spatiale mir cas d'une station russe et
retour au sol baikonour et le fuel le
deuxième volet d'une mission sur la
navette spatiale columbia à partir de
cap canaveral avec un équipage américain
qui a permis de mettre dans l'espace à
un télescope spatial qui s'appelle
chambre a qui travaillent sur la gamme
des rayons x dans le premier vol russe
était à un rôle d expérimentateurs
scientifique médical avec principalement
une expérience sur l'échographie et sur
l'expérience d'euros sensorielle alors
que chez américain j'étais plutôt
ingénieur de bord pour le déploiement du
télescope champ droit la différence
principale c'est les véhicules devant
puisque les américains d'école sur une
navette qui est un navet qui est un
avion puis une station puis encore en
avion alors que les russes ont un
vaisseau et une saison spéciale c'est un
sentiment assez étrange parce que vous
voyez la terre d'une façon particulière
comme on l'a gérée vue vous voyez les
étoiles avec tout en couleurs vous voyez
toutes les étoiles sans aucun frein
atmosphérique ou nuageux vous voyez le
sel qui n'aura vous voyez des planètes
comme on les a jamais vus donc c'est
vraiment une plate forme d'observation
de la terre et des astres qui est
vraiment mon particulière je pense qu'on
a on doit pas le quitter on doit y
rester parce que c'est une chance
d'avoir participé à ce domaine là et je
pense qu'on a le devoir de continuer à
apprendre ce qui se passe dans l'espace
et à transmettre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec
l'expérience que nous avons eues dans
l'espace aujourd'hui elle est vraiment
très très bien par des projets qui sont
fabuleux comme la station spatiale
internationale qui a montré quand même
que l'union mondiale le peut fonctionner
sur tendre les russes et américains et
donc les projets futurs en coopération
sont tout à fait faisable et toutes les
coopérations qui sont même aujourd'hui
impensable sont posés dans le futur et
que diriez vous un jeune qui voudrait
faire comme vous un jour voyager qu'ils
qui le pense à le faire qu'ils cherchent
à le faire c'est le donnera des ailes
pour étudier et s'il y arrive tant mieux
s'il reste faible nord est est proche
des étoiles
merci de nous avoir suivis c'est la fin
de cette édition prochain 7,8 les
invités mardi 18h45 pour la première
diffusion toutes nos archives sur notre
site internet excellente soirée
[Musique]